was gone this is nathan drake he is the
hero of our game uncharted 2 which is
our new game for the playstation 3 which
comes out in october and with this game
we really set out to create a playable
cinematic action-adventure so we ended
up with a story about Nathan Drake who
is a fortune hunter he's a guy who has
one foot in the legitimate world of
archaeology and artifact reclamation and
another foot in the shady world of
international historical art theft very
much a world of double-dealing and of
bandits and dodgy crime world figures in
the first game we put Nate in a very
specific situation where he was kind of
forced into a hero role but with this
game we have a much greater cast of
characters many of whom you play
alongside as AI control characters in
the game who will help and sometimes
hinder Nate as he progresses through the
game while there have been plenty of
multiplayer shooting games there hasn't
ever really been a game which is about
traversal combat in the way that are
given is not just traversal shooting
either but we have loads more melee
combat hand-to-hand it really is good
old-fashioned hand-to-hand slugging it
out it's very kind of sloppy the
fighting in uncharted it's not like the
kind of precise martial arts style
fighting that you get it's much more
kind of good old-fashioned you know
bare-knuckle brawl everything that you
see on screen in terms of the increased
fidelity of the shaders which are the
things that define like the surfaces of
the of the objects just have a
incredible variety compared to the first
game and so now like skin really looks
like skiing accounts
light in a way the skin read this cloth
looks a lot different we have a lot more
variation in the kind of subtleties of
different kinds of stone and metal and
stuff like that we have kind of a unique
production process as far as the
performances of our actors go a lot of
people just kind of get actors in one by
one into an ADR studio and record them
and then send them home with a paycheck
but we will free start we have a
director of actors a guy named Gordon
Hunt who has many years of theatre and
film and television under his belt and
the other naughty dogs they work
alongside Gordon with the actors to
first of all workshop the scenes I'll do
lots of table readings and they'll
they'll block the scenes because we're
recording on a motion-capture stage of
course and and they part of that process
they do quite a lot of improvisation and
in fact some of the funniest lines in
the game just come straight from the
brains of the actors in the moment you
know when they're when they're
improvising at work shopping were the
Roberto has been biting at my heels you
better pray that he is not Bluff that
means that when we're on the stage and
we're now capturing audio dialogue on
the stage as well as as the physical
performances the actors have a really
good sense of where they are in the
overall flow of the drama and how their
relationships stand to one another in
that moment which I think really comes
through in the performances and I think
that's what people are responding to
when they hear a line of dialogue that
rings true for them or a joke that comes
off it's really all of that effort
that's gone into it
you